ladies gentlemen hold on to your wigs
and keys it's time to start passing out
Academy Awards that's right when you
hear your name please come to the stage
in an orderly single-file and pick up
your Oscar we should all be home in
about a half an hour the first award of
the evening is for Best Supporting
Actress here to present it is a man who
not only won an Academy Award for his
fine work in the fugitive but also
actually appeared in every movie
released last year
ladies and gentlemen Oscar winner Tommy
Lee Jones
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
five talented women found five demanding
roles this year and by breathing life
into them they have won our admiration
and respect and one of them is about to
win an Oscar for Best Performance by an
actress in a supporting role the
nominees are rosemary Harris and Tom and
viv Helen Mirren in the madness of King
George uma Thurman in Pulp Fiction
jennifer Tilly and bullets over Broadway
Dianne Wiest in bullets over Broadway
and the Oscar goes to Dianne Wiest in
drama
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh golly
oh gosh just let me put on my glasses
because this is as surprising and
marvelous as it was the first time
although this time I need glasses the
difference but I'm so privileged to be
in the company of these gifted women
including Jennifer Tilly my colleague
who's so wonderful
I'm in debt to my loyal friend and
remarkable artist Woody Allen he gave me
such a gift with this role and with this
gift came acting with John Cusack being
lit by the great cinematographer Carlo
De Palma costume by Jeffrey Curlin
working with Santo Lacroix stole a great
cast a great crew my thanks also to
Tracey Jacobs Bobby Greenhut Jean de
manian and Harvey and Bob Weinstein I
have to thank my family Martha Harris
Yulin Kathleen Tolan my brothers Greg
and Donnie Clarice the Steve testa jizz
Arlene Donovan and my sweet daughters
their sweet patients Emily and Lily
without whom nothing is anything and Sam
Cohen is their Godfather if the world
was a perfect place every kid would have
a godfather like Sam
[Music]